jacques attali est cette semaine
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous donc assurées
à ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec
life et avec les échos et radio
classique
vous êtes avec nous un moment vous avez
décidé de quelle manière de faire
entendre votre voix dans le débat
présidentiel jacques attali et donc vous
répondrai au cours de cette émission à
trois grandes questions d'abord le
piratant les français à vous lire avec
françois fillon est ce que vous n'êtes
pas dans la caricature vous répondrez à
jean francis pécresse
ensuite comment pouvez vous imaginer une
primaire allant de macron à mélenchon
vous l'a jugé possible souhaitable
marc préel de la fp vous interrogera à
ce sujet enfin que proposerait
aujourd'hui une commission attali pour
la croissance mais qu'elle a metz vous
le demandera alors que vous développez
vous à vos idées pour pour sortir de
l'impasse et vous encourager par
ailleurs les acteurs d'un monde meilleur
avec la fondation que vous présidez
positive planète mais d'abord jacques
attali une question d'actualité
manuel valls on l'a suivi ces derniers
jours a mis en scène sa stratégie de la
tension avec françois hollande
est ce qu'on peut parler de crise de
régime on aurait pu parler de crise de
régime si le prévenu avait démissionné
ou s'il s'était présenté en essayant de
rester près unissent mais il ne l'a pas
fait donc tout ça est pour l'instant une
tempête dans un verre d'eau
et quand même personne n'est dupe quand
même de cet apaisement qui a été annoncé
avec ce déjeuner en tête-à-tête à
l'elysée on sait que manuel valls n'a
renoncé à rien est ce que la guerre
quand même et déclarait toujours très à
droite on a connu ça aussi une bataille
entre les différents candidats possibles
à l'élection présidentielle il y aura la
même chose à gauche qui a déjà commencé
entre tous ceux qui sont candidats à
gauche à l'élection présidentielle ça
rejoint votre question précédente
est ce qu'il y aura une primaire de
toutes les gauches et moi je peux vous
dire elle aura lieu alors n'en parlera
mais là on parle quand même du duo de
l'exécutif après la plus important c'est
qu'ils se concentrent sur l'exercice de
leur métier comme premier ministre y
compris dans la pluie c'est très
important ça a l'air aussi un obstacle
pour moi pour voir l'un ou l'autre
devenir candidat à l'élection primaire
en restant dans leur fonction parce que
l'élection primaire on l'a vu avec les
candidats de droite ça prend beaucoup de
temps
il est très difficile d'être pagny et
président d'un public n'est que vous
avez entendu vous avez lu encore
dimanche bien sûr ces interviews qui a
tout a tout accéléré
manuel valls qui envisageait de se
présenter contre françois hollande et ça
ça n'est pas là quand même manqué
incroyablement déloyauté non d'abord ce
qu'il le dit de façon très transparente
il pourrait très bien le faire mais je
n'ai pas donné pas d'obstacle à ça ça me
paraît pas avant alors on vous écoute
tout est normal non ces signes à un
homme politique
la moindre des choses c'est qu'il ait
envie de devenir président république
c'est même la seule fonction vraiment
intéressante dans la république donc que
manuel valls est en devenir présente lui
que ça paraît tout à fait sain et en
plus il le dit de façon transparente et
il n'a pas créé des conditions d'une
rupture avant de le faire vous êtes le
premier quand même a dit la trouvez ça
normal
1 je trouverai une façon de défier le
président de la république soit c'est
pas défier
je veux pas c'est pas défier cetc c'est
dire qu'il se met sur les rangs pour
tous ceux qui souhaitent et je vous le
dit la primaire totale aura lieu je vais
vous dire dans quelles conditions
d'accord ben on verra ça dans un instant
encore une question quand même sur cette
crise de régime que vous niez quand même
ça donne des arguments à la droite on
l'a encore entendu aujourd'hui dénoncé
l'incapacité de l'exécutif
et puis la perte d'autorité du président
se sont effet là que vous contestez
également le président ne se mêle pas de
cette bagarre il laisse son premier
ministre et d un réseau de s'exprimer je
pense pas qu'il ya perte d'autorité plus
spécialement dans ce cas là c'est vrai
que tout le monde attend de la question
de la question de savoir s'il sera
candidat ou pas et donc ça donne un
sentiment d'amertume en fallait encore
totalement et plein de façon pleine et
entière j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec lui aujourd'hui président de la
république il exerce ses fonctions
pleinement et la république et tous les
français qu'ils soient de gauche ou de
droite n'ont pas intérêt à ce que le
président soit affaibli surtout il ya
des menaces autour du pays vous avez
déjeuné avec lui par tête à tête
confidences à vous révéler pas de
confidence mais quand même une
impression vous avez tiré une impression
de sa volonté de se présenter ou sans
tirer la conclusion que le président l'a
public est présent là public et qui fait
son métier à fond d'accord quand même on
se dit qu'une telle guerre entre les
deux têtes de l'exécutif haute et aurait
été impensable du temps de françois
mitterrand avait vous moquez de mémoire
parce que là eu lieu avec une violence
extrême
d'abord évidemment sous la cohabitation
avec jacques chirac et avec et le vol à
dieu puis avec michel rocard s'était pas
tendre du tout c'était même extrême
beaucoup plus dur que ça ne l'est
aujourd'hui
oui mais c'était dur de la part du chef
de l'état à l'encontre du premier
ministre à celle inverse sera le citoyen
c'est ça indique quand même ce n'est pas
tout à fait nouveau et on peut retrouver
d'autres traces il ya eu aussi sous
giscard d'estaing avec chirac qui était
d'une extrême violence
d'accord bon on attend maintenant la
décision du chef de l'état vous avez
déjeuné à sa table aujourd'hui jacques
attali nous étions donc il s'est amusé
comme ça à jouer avec les nerfs de tout
le monde
non je n'ai pas de confidence
particulier à faire je suis pour ma part
convaincu que ce psychodrame a cessé un
moment ou un autre
d'une façon ou d'une autre je n'ai pas
la réponse je ne la connais pas une mais
n'a pas fait cette confiance mais je
crois que le plus important aujourd'hui
c'est que en temps plein en public et
fasse son métier de prison
nick est que le candidat six candidats
il ya s'exprime le plus tard possible le
plus tard possible c'est mon point de
vue d'accord il nous a pas fait de
confidences mais peut-être que vous vous
lui avez dispenser un conseil ou
plusieurs mais c'est arrivé déjà je n'ai
mis sur la place publique j'ai dit ce
qui me paraissait nécessaire c'est que
le présent à pluie ne soit pas candidat
à la primaire du parti socialiste
primaires qui ne peut désigner que le
perdant puisque cette primaire est
étroite donc comme sûrs à d'autres
candidats ne peut les nier que le
perdant que s'il veut être candidat il
va être candidat
urbi et orbi c'est à dire en tant que
président la pluie or la primaire et
c'est son droit et qu' ils fassent
l'impossible pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une primaire avant le premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle de tous les
candidats
sinon cette primaire aura lieu quoi
qu'il arrive parce que la primaire de la
gauche sera le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle qui désignera
le meilleur camp de la gauche mais ça
sera complètement idiot parce que le
meilleur candidat de la gauche sera
forcément troisième avec le
présidentialisme gagnants dont
l'absurdité de refuser une primaire de
toutes les gauches c'est d'assumer que
la première de toutes les gauches et la
primaire perdante du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle ok on
reparlera de la primaire et de vos
propositions dans un instant mais
d'abord c'est jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique que nous on accueille pour la
première partie de l'émission
grand soir jean françaix bonsoir michel
bonsoir jacques attali alors dans une
tribune publiée hier dans le monde vous
écrivez que en substance si françois
fillon était élu président de la
république les français auraient droit à
travailler plus à plus de précarité et à
plus d'impôts est ce que c'est pas un
tout petit peu caricatural on ne vous
reconnais pas dans ce jugement un peu à
l'emporte-pièce d'abord j'ai pas nier
que des contres travailler plus c'est
les hivers plus de flexibilité c'est
nécessaire et travailler plus longtemps
pour internet c'est nécessaire équité
contre doivent pas mon raisonnement est
plutôt de dire puisque je m'adresse à la
gauche
dans cet article je dis si je
reviendrais sur le programme de france
korian jeudi si vous gens de gauche
vous pensez vraiment que c'est
cataclysmique ce qui pourrait avec
fillon alors créer les conditions pour
le battre ne vous occupez pas que de
vous même mais créer les conditions pour
pouvoir le battre
donc vous vous êtes pas cohérent si vous
dites à la fois c'est épouvantable ce
qui nous attend et françois fillon et si
vous créez pas les conditions pour le
battre est maintenant revenue au
programme de temps votre rapport que
vous aviez publié en 2008 le rapport
pour la libération de la croissance
française vous préconisiez déjà un
certain nombre de choses que préconise
france absolument et je devrais je suis
entièrement d'accord avec un grand
nombre de propositions de françois
fillon je suis entièrement d'accord avec
un grand nombre de propositions de
françois fillon en particulier ce qu'il
dit sur la russie ce qui du sur
l'évolution du travail et beaucoup de
choses sur lesquelles je suis pas
d'accord la réforme de l'école je la
vois pas comme ça à la réforme de la
fonction publique je la vois pas comme
ça mais enfin je suis d'accord sur
certaines dimensions de ces d'autant
plus amusant s'il faut rappeler ce
souvenir c'est que la commission que
m'avait demandé de présider nicolas sûr
que j'y suis pas nicolas sarkozy qui me
l'a demandé si c'est françois fillon
françois fillon m'a appelé pour me
demander de présider cette commission et
je les fais avec
il ya dix ans je le fais un grand
plaisir si c'est une commission
bipartisane
ensuite nicolas sarkozy a cosigné la
lettre de mission que m'a demandé
françois fillon qui avait eu l'idée et
j'ai merveilleuse mon travail avec
françois fillon dans l'exercice de ce
rapport dans sa préparation j'ai eu tous
les moyens pour travailler ça s'est très
bien passé les pendant les cinq ans où
il était premier ministre je venais le
voir très souvent où il m'appelait très
souvent
voir dans quelles conditions ce rapport
pouvait être mise en oeuvre et j'ai
toujours eu le sentiment ressenti avec
lui et avec le président que c'était le
président qui l'empêché de mettre en
oeuvre le rapport dit que lui-même me
disait très souvent ah si je pouvais je
ferai tout tout de suite je ne sais pas
s'il leur est fait mais en tout cas j'ai
senti quelqu'un qui avait véritablement
la vie de fer au point même que je lui
ai dit à plusieurs reprises
vous devriez menacé de démissionner
c'est la seule façon pour abreuver nice
d'exercer ses responsabilités alors
précisément qu'est ce qui vous plaît
dans son projet présidentiel
d'abord je sais j'aime le courage
j'aime la méthode d'agir vite j'ai fait
moi-même un programme présidentiel qui
est paru il ya quelques mois et on peut
comparer ce qui et comment elles ce qui
ne l'est pas j'aime la méthode d'agir
vite tout de suite de faire tout très
vite
j'aime le fait de proposer de créer les
conditions de d'égaliser les conditions
de la retraite de tous les français
d'augmenter la tva plutôt que les impôts
directs de réduire les charges de
réduire l'impôt sur les sociétés tout ça
me c'est exactement ce qu'il ya dans le
programme que j'ai présenté mes mains
c'est pour ça que j'ai été un peu étonné
de vous voir prendre position contre
l'augmentation d'impôts parce qu'il n'y
a pas véritablement dans le programme
président affi en dehors de la tva
d'augmentation d'arles est faible c'est
pourquoi j'ai dit tout haut des baisses
d'impôts s'est dit plutôt si vous genre
de gauche vous êtes dans ce discours
alors créé les conditions de la com vous
y opposer sur ce point je poursuis même
aussi assez favorable très favorable
parce que je le dis depuis très
longtemps c'est pas lui qui m'ont pas
convaincu à une autre attitude à l'égard
de la russie
pour moi ça fait trente ans que je
considère que là aussi fait partie de
l'europe
c'est une absurdité de l'avoir isolé est
une grande erreur de la politique de
étrangères de l'actuel président être
son ancien muniesa fais étrangères que
d'avoir participé à l' isolement de la
russie c'est une immense erreur et donc
je pense en effet que nos adversaires
principaux sont à mossoul et pas moscou
ni la dame à ce qui est un adversaire
épouvantable qui n'est pas le premier
d'entre eux que de ce point de vue je
suis d'accord avec je suis évidemment
pas d'accord du tout avec lui
1 sur toutes les questions de moeurs sur
la remise en cause de la loi taubira je
suis pas d'accord sur l'entrée et
subreptice du fait religieux dans la
république qui me paraît extrêmement
dangereux parce que si on discours
public en tout cas d'haïti cirh si on
look si on autorise aux catholiques
pourquoi le refuser aux musulmans et ça
créera et aux autres régions ça ça ouvre
une boîte de pandore extrêmement
dangereuse
vous avez vous avez voté à la primaire
de la droite non vous auriez pu voter
sinon j'aurais j'aurais pu bosser c'est
très compliqué les gens de gauche
puisque je suis de gauche
les gens de gauche ont pu voter pour
fillon pour battre sarkozy ce qu'ils ont
fait plancher que juppé pour battre
fillon ou voter pour fillon je connais
dans les deux cas qui ont voté soit
juppé pour battre lyon ou fillon parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est le meilleur
adversaire possible pour la gauche
est ce que vous ne craignez pas quand
même que un rapprochement avec vladimir
poutine pourrait se faire au détriment
de l'europe et c'est ce que craignent
notamment nos partenaires allemands
alors d'abord je suis pour continuer les
compliments j'aime beaucoup le discours
de françois fillon sur l'europe et en
particulier sur la essayer de renforcer
l'intégration avec l'allemagne la
coopération sur trois points qu'ils
proposent c'est tout à fait des choses
que moi j'ai proposé depuis longtemps et
donc je suis d'avis qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
mais je peux paraître c'est un peu
avancé des bars et un peu aussi la faute
désormais il a interrogé puisque ils
n'ont pas dérogé ni sur le climat ni sur
la révolution numérique ni ni sur
l'europe
étrange lacunes mais le pour moi et
c'est un sujet philosophique très
important pour moi la russie est en
europe
il ne faut absolument pas faire la même
erreur avec la russie qu'on a fait avec
la turquie la turquie on a isolé et
moralité ça a donné ce que ça donne
c'est à dire une dictature épouvantable
qui évidemment n'est plus en europe qui
a choisi si on fait la même chose avec
la russie on aura la même résultat donc
la russie pour moi est en europe
d'ailleurs surprend les discours de
poutine à son arrivée au pouvoir il
avait même laissé entendre qu'il voulait
rejoindre l'union européenne
et pour moi la littérature russe la
musique russes montrent que la russie
est une nation européenne
donc il faut pas opposer la russie et
l'europe et vers l'allemagne est tout à
fait sur cette ligne et je pense qu'on a
une nouvelle perspective intéressante
est ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à parler
avec assad
non je pense qu'il faut considérer que
notre ennemi premier est à mossoul et
que notre ennemi seconde est à est à
damas mais il faut pas parler avec assad
j'étais à beyrouth la semaine dernière
ou pour proposer qui planète pour voir
tout ce qui se passe avec la tragédie
des réfugiés je veux dire ne pas rouvrir
une ambassade un parent garde au nom
rouvrir une ambassade de rouvrir une
ambassade a maintenant d'abord les
conditions ne sont pas réunies de
sécurité sont pas réunies et d'autres
nous avons à l'ambassadeur mais qui
n'est pas à damas on va revenir aux
propositions économiques et sociales de
françois fillon je vous propose de
l'écouter ce que hier soir il a affirmé
ce qu'il disait d'ailleurs durant sa
campagne qu'il ne veut pas amender son
projet et il a donc vous n'aurez affirmé
qu'il ne bougerait parents l'écoutent
suis pas candidat pour m'asseoir dans un
fauteuil à l'elysée attendre que le
temps passe je suis candidat pour
redresser mon pays j'ai la conviction
que le seul projet qui permet de
redresser
mon pays c'est un projet qui grosso modo
peut se résumer de la manière suivante
il faut qu'on travaille un petit peu
plus parce qu'on travaille moins que
tous les autres européens
il faut qu'on dépense un peu moins
d'argent public puisqu'on n'en dépense
plus que tous les autres européens
donc c'est autour de ce projet là que je
vais continuer d'avancer
alors je crois que c'est pas tout à fait
exact de dire qu'on travaille plus que
moins que les autres européens les
statistiques se discute on se raconte
pas leur parole deuxièmement je crois
qu'il ya débat qui aurait commencé à
ouvrir avec peu de gens ouverts c'est
que c'est la question des élections
législatives parce que président en
fuite n'a aucun pouvoir sur les sujets
dont il vient de parler c'est le
parlement qui en décide et donc il est
très important de savoir s'il va avoir
une majorité et avoir une majorité sont
négociés avec des partenariats d'accueil
qui l'a fait dans l'histoire récente
c'est françois mitterrand 1981 quand il
avait une majorité écrasante pour un
programme décidé à l'avancé qu'on a pu
et je suis exister en trois voies après
plus personne n'a eu cette majorité il a
fallu négocier tôt je pense que le futur
président un public qui qu'ils soient
ils auraient majorité aura besoin de
négocier avec ses partenaires
est-ce que cinq cent mille postes de
fonctionnaires en moins dans les cinq
années est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui possible pas parce que vous savez
que c'est le grand débat de savoir si
c'est le réaliste ou pas d'abord ces
cinq cent mille comptant les
collectivités locales ce dimanche
donc c'est impossible sans réformer la
constitution parce que la constitution
dans l'état actuel ne permet pas au
président rappelait l état au général de
toucher aux personnels des collectivités
locales qui peuvent augmenter les impôts
comme ils veulent de ce cinq cent mille
n'a pas de sens puisque il compte deux
cent cinquante mille de collectivités
locales sur lequel l'état n'aura aucun
pouvoir
premièrement deuxièmement il ya des tas
de secteurs où il faut
le nombre de personnel en particulier
dans l'éducation et dans la santé et
dans la police et dans l'armée
donc si vous augmentez ça ou vous les
enlevez moi je pense que les vrais
progrès seront à faire par le numérique
progressivement mais on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui dans l'état actuel des
besoins sécurité en défense en santé et
en éducation parler d'une telle
réduction du personnel sur sauf les
collectifs sur l'éducation l'emploi
voilà justement est-ce que vous avez vu
aujourd'hui paraître une étude très
importante à ce trafic catastrophique
pour le niveau des écoliers français en
maths et en sciences
pour faire clair on est derniers
auvergne et de l'union européenne cela
on est très très mal classés dans les 50
pays de là encore dans une rencontre
dans le rapport quoi dans la proposition
de programme présidentiel que j'avais
fait au mois d'avril sous le nom de
france 2022 visant à ce qu'on pourrait
obtenir en france mais ne jamais
assister comme preuve nous avions
c'était un grand collectif insisté sur
comme première réforme qui n'est pas
repris par françois fillon la réforme de
l'école maternelle pour donner davantage
de moyens à l'école maternelle dans les
quartiers défavorisés nous sommes en
effet une question de moyens si j'ai
bien regardé l'étude
parce que le nombre d'heures des
écoliers français est supérieur à celui
de leurs voisins parfois c'est une
question de pour moi tout se joue et les
études sur montrer celles de l'osce et
du pisa celle de l'institut montaigne
tous les rapports montrent que tout se
joue à l'école maternelle et qu' un
petit nombre de jeunes français arrivent
en primaire en parlant 1500 mo est qu un
bon tiers sinon plus
arrivée en parlant 300 mots c'est fini
c'est réglé et c'est là où se pose le
problème deuxième partie de l'épreuve de
vérité maintenant avec marc presles de
la fp qui nous rejoint pour parler
justement de la primaire de gauche
l'épreuve de vérité avec la fp
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur attali alors on
a vous en avez parlé vous en propose
proposé aujourd'hui dans le monde dans
le journal le monde vous en avait parlé
à quelques instants sur ce plateau
vous imaginez en fait une primaire qui
rassemble de mélenchon à macron comment
vous pouvez imaginer une seule seconde
que ce qui a été refusé depuis des
semaines
clairement par ces candidats peu puisse
encore se passer
d'abord il faut que l'opinion publique
prennent conscience que j'ai pris
mercredi tout à l'air aura lieu parce
que le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est une primaire de la
gauche
accessoirement puisqu'ils seront tous là
et à nos reins qui sera évidemment mieux
placé que les autres donc la première de
la gauche même s'ils veulent éviter l
aura lieu à ce moment là naturellement
ça ne désignera qu'un troisième parce
que à une peine et françois fillon son
avance est complètement idiot si cette
primaire qui aura lieu de toute façon
avait lieu avant dans ce cas là eh bien
elle décide à quelqu'un qui pourrait
avoir une chance d'être devant marine le
pen et donc on l'aurait second tour
monsieur x contre monsieur fillon ce qui
serait quand même plus conforme à l'idée
que je me fais de la france dont c'est
la seule chance de la gauche d'être au
2eme c'est la seule chance de la gauche
a tenu à lorsque les candidats en
question autant ted c'est je vais
avancer tout seul et au mois de février
je fais exploser les autres parce que
les sondages vont mettre en tête et
personne n'osera résister à cette
question si vous restez vous tuer la
gauche donc je fais campagne tout seul
en février monsieur mélenchon monsieur
montebourg
monsieur filoche monsieur macro pense
qu'ils seront 15 % des voix et que les
autres dans cinq réseaux sera obligé de
s'incliner ça peut pas se produire c'est
suicidaire si le crois vraiment ils ont
qu'à faire une primaire mais il ya déjà
des sondages qui donnent des indications
précieuses aujourd'hui sur les avantages
des uns et des autres avec v comme
dirait qu'ils se détachent notamment on
voit là un sondage aujourd'hui qui donne
macron à 17% le président la république
est très loin à 8%
est ce que justement ça leur évite pas
ce scénario désir tient peut-être un des
candidats va se détacher les autres
renom seront de fait je crois pas qu'ils
renonceront je crois que le prêt bleus
partis sionistes pas renoncé à voir son
candidat si les gens que l'on se serait
suicidaire pour tout le monde mais il
renoncera pas il ne peut renoncer que
s'il ya une primaire de gauche
il désigne à conduite à gauche et jusque
là la famille rassemblée à désigner à
conduire mais si on va au bout ils
resteront je voulais revenir sauf
quelque chose que vous avez expliqué
commence à expliquer tout à l'heure
c'est que vous dites
certes on vous suit il faut rassembler
la gauche pour être au premier tour mais
là vous dites la primaire socialiste qui
se dessine avec françois hollande arnaud
montebourg benoît hamon
bah finalement ya plus besoin de la
faire pourquoi moi je conseille pas là
je pense que jk plus besoin de la faire
de ce qu'il faut une primaire d'ensemble
mais si cette primaire là ne se fait pas
cette primaire d'ensemble qui
probablement ne sera pas n'a pas lieu
-10 que françois hollande doit renoncer
à la primaire du ps oui mon conseil
personnel je ne dis pas que je serai
suivi c'est qu'il aille pas la primaire
parce que cette primaire 3-1 convenir
aux pressions d'un public et pour le
pays parce que le pays va t elle plus
que prison d'un public premier
inconvénient le président république
sera prix pourra pas faire son boulot de
prix dans le public parce qu'il sera
pris par des meetings partout à une
primaire deuxièmement cette primaire
c'est du quinquennat et on peut terminer
comme maintenant j'attends des normes de
travail il se passe énormément de choses
et la situation exige un homme à la
manette aux manettes ces pressions de la
publie deuxième conte ses conclusions
c'est complètement idiot de faire une
campagne pour une primaire qui va
désigner un père n'a aucun sens c'est
vraiment du du top du temps perdu
et troisièmement un show que la fonction
présidentielle le impose d'être soit le
candidat toute une famille large
assemblée soit candidat tout seul donc
moi je lui conseillerais net je ne je ne
dis pas qu'il le fera et j'ai pas d'avis
par deux états et de confidences
particulière mais je conseillerais de ne
pas être candidat à cette primaire est
candidat s'il le souhaite je ne sais pas
s'il sera d'être candidat en dehors
en tant que président un public tel
discours qu'on entend la ces dernières
car voilà vous n'êtes pas le seul à
délivrer ce qu'on s'approche de
résidence était folle qui ont qui ont
aujourd'hui moi je ne suis pas concertés
avec personne j'ai en effet des jeunes
et qui prévoit plus quand on a parlé
tout à fait autre chose n'a pas parlé à
une seconde et mais c'est ce que je
disais dans l'article l'espace hier à
lui dû du monde hier fait je ne lui
conseille pas d'être candidat comme je
conseille aux autres mélenchon au micro
emmanuel est un ami très proche je suis
très fier d'avoir été à l'origine aérien
de sa carrière et c'est un très
intéressant et je suis convaincu qu'il
sera un jour président je suis convaincu
qu est le sera un jour s'il sylla la
persistance de 2,2
d'accepter les fait d'apprendre je suis
convaincu qu'il le sera un jour vous
pouvez demander d'être patient je ne
mens pas je lui dis je le sais déjà
parce que nous en avons souvent parlé je
pense que il espère être président cette
fois ci mais je pense qu'il construit
une vraie carrière et que c'est très
courageux de sa part d'avoir alors qu'il
aurait pu faire tout à fait autre chose
d'avoir accepté de participer à la vie
démocratique on va l'écouter on va
écouter également jean-luc mélenchon
donc tout oppose sauf le refus de la
primaire je te crois que vous vous
promenez jacques attali mais donc chacun
a choisi son cheminement personnel on
les écoute moi je propose ma candidature
c'est le peuple qui va en disposer je me
demande la permission à personne je le
fais hors cadre de parti je suis ouvert
à tout le monde
les organisations les restos mais les
citoyens d'abord depuis six mois
tous les sondages montrent que la gauche
n'existe pas au second tour
je n'ai jamais été testée comme un
candidat de gauche mais comme un
candidat de rassemblement ce qui est mon
projet et ce rassemblement progressiste
et celui auquel je crois et que en effet
je suis aujourd'hui les sondages au
dessus du candidat de la gauche mais je
pense que la gauche n'a pas besoin de
moi pour perdre oui lits simples dit le
contraire puisqu'il a aussi dit qu'il
était un homme de gauche donc clarifié
le discours là la vraie chance pour
avoir un candidat de la gauche parce que
mène le maquereau on peut dire ce qu'il
veut mais où il est candidat de la
gauche où il compte bien nulle part il
n'est pas c'est pas je pense pas
peut-être que je me trompe mais je pense
pas qu'un candidat de nulle part puisse
se gagner l'élection présidentielle mais
pas tout monsieur trump a gagné en étant
nulle part donc c'est pas juste sur les
41 je pense que le plus ce qui peut
changer c'est que grande manifestation
du pays et des gens de gauche demande
exige une première du pied gauche j'ai
lancé moi même une une pétition sur
change.org il ya déjà presque mais
personnes quelques heures qui ont signé
pour que les français demandent cette
primaire et on peut même rêver dans la
rue par internet c'est plus simple j'ai
réglé le plus discret mais on peut même
aussi rêver de l'organiser cette
primaire
sans les candidats d'organiser une
primaire sans que les candidats le soir
souligné leur absence pour souligner
leur absence et faire cette primaire je
voulais juste citoyenne où les citoyens
décident de voter pour les condamnant
vous accueillez savez vous mettez les
mains dans le cambouis la jauge des eaux
peut imaginer je dis pas que je lui fais
imaginer faire juste pour revenir sur le
décalage entre jean luc mélenchon ce
spectre en fait qui va de jouets
d'enfants emmanuel macron vous écrivez
aujourd'hui dans le monde qu' il n'y a
pas deux il ya les mêmes il n'y a pas
autant de différence entre jean françois
poisson
jean frédéric poisson pardon et et
henkel et jean luc mélenchon et même
macron vous exagérez
ah non je crois pas je crois pas je
crois vraiment que les différences sont
sont aussi grandes jean-françois pour ce
poisson c'est jean frédéric poisson
c'est les extrêmes qu'il est nathalie
kosciusko ce le hasard de la vie qui n'a
bien droite elle aurait pu être à gauche
comme emmanuel macron aurait pu être à
droite
il est venu à gauche par ce même
beaucoup de choses communes dans les
programmes de droite même s'il y avait
des oui mais il ya aussi beaucoup de
choses communes entre les idées de la
caisse qui a justement dans les idées de
jean luc mélenchon d'emmanuel macron
c'est vrai qu'on a envie de vous
entendre il ya le refus des injustices
qui me paraît fondamental chez eux comme
un vraiment commun il ya la passion pour
l'europe parce qu on oublie que jean luc
mélenchon et pro-européen j'ai souvent
débattu avec lui quelquefois les battues
avec lui les pro européens et pour
l'euro donc ça c'est quand même un point
commun et c'est des points
lutter contre les inégalités et
renforcer la zone euro
c'est quand même les des points
fondamentaux autour duquel s'articulent
beaucoup de choses communes
je vais revenir sur la juste des
questions sur la primaire qui était
cette primaire elle a été conçue à
gauche par le parti socialiste par jean
christophe cambadélis pour servir de
tremplin à françois hollande qui était
décrédibiliser de dire voilà il va
paribas gagné un premier round et ça va
le relancer pour la campagne aujourd'hui
on voit qu'il est en situation difficile
il ya des sondages qui le donnent à
touche touche avec arnaud montebourg
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le fait de
renoncer à cette primaire on va dire
socialiste puisque de fait il n'y a plus
que le ps c'est pas une façon de reculer
en disant ah beh peut la perdre je n'y
vais pas vous soyez pas amnésiques les
sondages
homme de monsieur trump les sondages du
brésil tous les sondages de monsieur
fillon conduisent à ceux qui ont les
plus mauvais sondages à voir les plus
grands experts un homme c'est pas gagné
personne aujourd'hui on peut dire c'est
gagner à 100 % pour françois hory
tournage sont une source d'espérance
les hommes politiques de moi comme ça
parce que votre proposition n'arrive pas
trop tard aujourd'hui on al impression
qu effectivement votre idée ne pourra
jamais oui où il peut être trop tôt il
s'est garé non peut-être trop tôt et
vous assez tôt pour que le moi je crois
beaucoup que l'opinion publique peut
leur imposer la bataille des ego est un
suicide pour la gauche la bataille des
ego et un suicide pour la gauche
et si ensuite monsieur fillon
l'emportent et que la gauche proteste
contre la politique à elle qu'il mène on
pourra très facilement leur dire c'est
votre faute si vous aviez créé les
conditions d'une vraie primaire ce ne
serait pas arrivé
la gauche portera la responsabilité des
reproches qu'elle fera au président la
pluie ou de droite c'est entièrement de
sa faute
donc ça c'est quand même un argument
très lourd on parlait de manuel
d'emmanuel macron ça a été votre
collaborateur employé comme françois
hollande 22 et est ce que ces ironies le
dr aujourd'hui vous avez été il était
mon collaborateur dans une commission
initié par françois fillon voyez le
monde est minuscule
qu'est ce que je peux dire donnant vous
pouvez dire de lui je vous dis c'est un
garçon remarquable très intelligent
plein promesses j'ai dit à la fois des
choses favorables et les choses dures
sur lui que je lui ai d'ailleurs
toujours bien drivé je crois que je
persiste à penser qu'il faut un
programme pour être candidat
présidentiel un programme clivant il dit
ce qu'il veut il pas à chier au milieu
j'ai eu droit aujourd'hui à grands pas
et c'est encore un certain moi je n'ai
pas encore lu son livre je suppose qu'il
ya des choses dedans qui précise les
choses mais pour l'instant je ne vois
pas un programme et à prendre forcément
ça vous fait des ennemis des gens qui
sont pas d'accord mais des gens qui sont
d'accord il faut qu'on se bat pour
quelque chose
la fondation positive l'année pour
travaillons dans l'intérêt des
générations suivantes
après d'un public pour moi c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille dans l'intérêt
de la chanson hymne à cette seule
fonction qu'est ce que je fais pour le
pays dont pour les gens changent et ce
point de vue emmanuel mal qu'on est le
seul de tous les hommes politiques
aujourd'hui qui sera là dans 30 ans
vraisemblablement et au plus haut ainsi
on vous serez semblablement il peut
l'être en tout cas donc il est mieux
placé que les autres pour parler au nom
de ce que sera la france en 2040
j'aimerais qu'il le fasse c'est quoi la
france de 2040 ou je voudrais qu'elle
aille
qu'est ce que je fais pour ça qu'ils
proposent les choses ambitieuse et c'est
ça ou on navigue que j'attends de lui
voir le vivier qui il était il l'a dit
lui même qu'il n'est ni à gauche ni à
droite extrait ce qui a pas un espace au
centre pour lui notamment après la
défaite d'alain juppé la france est
ainsi fait qu'il ya pas ce genre d'
espace quatre centres en france
le centre françois mitterrand disait je
suis formule qu'il m'invite encore vrai
le centre regarder au fond de la classe
à droite
merci d'avoir été avec nous la crémerie
merci beaucoup mais quel bon soir à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
qui